foreign
if you go on vacation for three weeks
stuff happens while you're gone yeah a
lot
you were gone so first thing happened
Supreme Court rules and says um
President Joe Biden does not have the
power to forgive student loans
second thing that happens is Joe Biden
came out with an announcement that they
were forgiving a bunch of student loans
which was actually a complete falsehood
because the student loan process already
involved forgiveness for people that did
the uh the PLC Public Service uh process
and it was 10 years and now it's going
to be 25 years and you just went on a
rant last week about that which has now
got over 300 000 views that's right rent
yeah and so it's not the same
forgiveness guys it's not it's not it's
not student loan forgiveness at all no
it was by the way by the way of the
people that signed up for that when it
was a 10-year program that are now
coming up on 10 years almost no one has
gotten less than five percent of the
people who've actually gotten the
Forgiveness so one more time the
government lied to you whether they're
Republicans or whether they're Democrats
it doesn't matter you can tell they're
lying about the student loan issue if
their mouth is moving that's right and
then this comes out today and this is
this one is not as maddening from the
daily wire as it is sad well this is sad
because this is about you the people a
third of student loan debt holders spent
the extra money that they thought would
be wiped clean so we know um I'll just
read this
um the poll by intelligent.com surveyed
977 people who would have qualified for
at least ten thousand dollars of relief
under Biden's plan now we know that was
struck down but you know we've all
talked about this so many people thought
oh I'm gonna get this forgiveness Dave
or people whose loans were paid off they
got that refund back of ten thousand
dollars and they thought and they didn't
they didn't get it they spent the money
and they earned that again they're in
debt again they were out of debtness put
them back in there that's right and uh
this this this came through and I
thought you know this is it because a
while back I was on here ranting saying
you guys were spending this money
on hamburgers and it looks like I'm a
little bit right it says of those one in
three people said they spent the extra
money because they were assuming
forgiveness and many of them spent the
money on things like vacations real
retail items
alcohol drugs and gambling
sounds responsible to me I would have
been happier with the hamburger
alcohol drugs and gambling okay we need
Dr John deloney in here but
this is unbelievable that's very
important I mean over half of borrowers
now say they don't feel prepared once
student loan repayment starts back up in
October with 35 saying they're very
unprepared well I mean
uh we got a little time let's get
prepared let's get prepared let's get
prepared guys apparently
gambling drugs alcohol retail and
vacations are not getting prepared no
that who knew that's you
know that that was not going to cause
wealth building yeah you're gonna have
to cut back on the Alcohol budget in the
gambling budget
and the Lululemon budget and the Sandals
vacation all-inclusive budget the
Supreme Court decision is a cold shower
for those who had their hopes pinned on
a ten thousand dollar relief James Allen
who founded personal finance website
Bullpen said uh it's like waiting for a
tax refund only to find out the IRS made
a mistake is it
is it though
no it's not because you never should
have been waiting on it we told you not
to wait on it we told you I told you to
use the time and get them get the stupid
but we're here now we're here now so now
you can get prepared since you feel
unprepared and the way you get prepared
is
um you start living on less than you
make and you quit waiting on anyone with
a zip code anywhere near Washington DC
to fix your life that's right and on a
prac even a more practical tip you guys
really need to don't bury your head in
the sand on this you need to go online
look at your service provider because
the fact is Dave a lot of the people a
lot of the servicers that were servicing
the loans pre-covered are no longer
they've been sold off to somebody else
so if you yeah if you've been getting
those emails and you've been ignoring
those Now's the Time to stop ignoring
the emails and really get organized find
out where your loan is or your loans are
find out how much what the full balance
is find out do not bury your head in the
sand find out what the payment's gonna
be all right you need to know this
information and then you need to start
looking at here's Dave this is the drum
I want to be
do not I repeat do not because some of
you that were in income driven repayment
plans prior to they're just
automatically enrolling you and yet
another income driven repayment plan
right and you can go on there yourself
and estimate your income and say this is
what I make this is what I want my
payment to be if you get an income
repayment plan you're going to be in
debt the rest the rest of your life and
that's what that mathematical you that's
the case it's not a philosophical
statement it's not a political that's
just a math thing that what you guys
heard us rant about last week about
Biden forgiveness that was people guys
that were in those income driven
repayment plans they had been paying 25
and 30 years is that what you really no
is that work
listen this is taking the student loan
business and applying the rules of the
DMV to it that's right this is stupid
government socialist Behavior yeah
that's who's working there and it's just
it's ridiculous and it's a disaster if
you lean on this for your future so your
future let me hit you you want to get
your student loans get rid of your
student loans here's how you do it
what we call Big math big math Works
somewhere around the fourth grade
so you owe ten thousand dollars okay
that's 833 dollars a month
or if you want to do it in one year okay
or it's sixteen hundred and sixty six
dollars a month if you want to do it in
six months okay it's ten it's a thousand
dollars a month if you wanna do it in 10
months it's five thousand dollars a
month if you wanna do it in two months
so take your take your student loan and
divide it by how long you want to be a
Slave
how many months and that tells you what
you've got to go make and get up off
your freaking couch
go leave the cave kill something and
drag it home and get this dead gum thing
out of your life this crap owns your
life and they're sitting up there in
Washington playing tiddlywinks with your
dad gum life and you gave them
permission yeah because you leaned on
something that didn't need to be leaned
on that wasn't worthy being leaned on
called politics and you're kidding
yourself
and you're gonna look up 10 years from
now and let me tell you any financial
situation that you have ignored
has a high rate of Resurrection as my
friend said that's right okay you try to
bury this stuff it comes back with a
Zombie Vengeance like six more zombies
than you had when you buried the first
one yeah it's gonna come back and it
comes back with a vengeance so he comes
back with extra fees extra gotchas
lawyer fees and all of a sudden they
show up at your work and garnish you
your dad gum wages so and they have
unlimited power to do this stuff that's
right that's right you do not want to
screw around with this take the dollars
that you owe today and divide it by the
number of months you want to be in pain
and then go get your pain over with
that's right get it done get it behind
you rip the Band-Aid off sell so much
stuff the kids think they're next yeah
hello I mean in this world you can make
some money right now there's a lot of
people paying a lot of money for people
to do
look Dave with the internet the way that
it is you could do you can do so much
there's so many ways to make money
please do not let these companies the
government fool you into thinking a
lower payment is better half of those in
the old in the old westerns
the uh you know the Indians were
attacking the the Pioneers the Pioneers
are circling the wagons and then you'd
hear this bugle sound and here comes the
calvary
to save them right so what Jade and I
are trying to tell you is the calvary
ain't coming
you're it
you're it look in the mirror you are
your financial salvation you and God
get a hold of his hands jump up get your
butt in gear and get to work and clean
this up take the amount of student loan
debt that you have the dollar amount and
divide it by the number of months you
want to be in pain and then go find that
much money in your budget or with extra
income and get it out of your life you
don't have to do the interest rate
division you don't have to do I want to
be and get the rest of my dadgum life
I'm going to be on income repayment
that's dumber than a rock that tells me
I don't know how you got out of the
sixth grade running that kind of math
that's dumb it's just dumb don't be dumb
dumb will make you broke this is the
Ramsey Show